you know what it never was
that's serious it was never that serious
quite frankly
will never be that serious Noah schnapp
is setting the record straight letting
the world know that he's well not oh my
God guys guys Noah 18.
oh my gosh
he posted his Revelation to Tick-Tock
writing when I finally told my friends
and family I was gay after being scared
in the closet for 18 years and all they
said was we know and then added some
humor in the caption I guess I'm more
similar to will than I thought I've been
having to hold in so much and honestly
it's gonna be weird because I've been
like I'm so used to not saying anything
so once I'm gonna be able to say it it's
gonna be like I can now it's just ah
freedom I can talk about it and I love
you
there is nothing in this world okay
absolutely nothing
I will ever change that
you got that yeah yeah
and and I'm always
here for you too I know
[Music]
you are come here
schnapp is of course referring to his
stranger things character will Byers
whose sexuality has been speculated
about by queer fans in season one
well
well I'd love to like let out everything
I've always wanted to just tell someone
everything I know but like I don't know
it's just I can't I mean it's better if
you don't know because then when you
watch the show you'll be surprised when
something happens
will sexuality was later addressed in
season four
a few months she's been been so lost
without you it's just she's so different
from other people and when you're when
you're different sometimes
you feel like a mistake
but you make her feel like she's not a
mistake at all like she's better for
being different and that gives her the
courage to fight on Elle needs you Mike
and she always will
[Music]
and Noah confirmed to Vogue over the
summer it was hinted at in season one it
was always kind of there now that he's
gotten older they made it a very real
obvious thing it is 100 clear that he is
gay I hope he's happy but I really I
love when he's suffering because that's
fun to play is anyone ever happy in the
show life imitates our people and we are
so happy to see Noah out and proud and
living his truth
foreign
[Music]